if you happen to be in the town of Lubec
Maine in July of 2016 you may have seen
something a little curious on the
horizon when you looked out across the
bay in the distance on an otherwise
uninhabited island loomed large black
letters that spelled the word forever
the sign was 15 feet tall and fifty feet
wide large and after that on a clear day
you really could see forever the word
perfectly visible and legible in the
distance but on some days a thick white
fog would roll in off the ocean erasing
the word and the view altogether and
sometimes like in this video you could
barely see forever peeking out of the
shifting fog accompanied only by the
rhythmic warning sounds of fog horns
[Music]
it started out as a fairly simple idea
albeit a little strange to put the word
forever in the landscape so it could
appear and disappear in the fog but it
took over a year to plan and execute and
it required the help of so many people
like the lobster boat captain who helped
transport all the materials to the
island and the volunteers who helped
carry thousands of pounds of wood and
steel to the top of the hill through
waist high shrubs and in the end forever
only lasted for three weeks so if you're
wondering why I did it at all as I often
did during that process it might help
for you to know a little bit more about
me and my upbringing I grew up in an
evangelical Christian family and
although I'm an atheist today I've
realised that my religious upbringing
has played a really important role in
shaping the person that I've become in
1986 when I was five years old my
parents became missionaries to South
Africa and that was during the last few
years of the apart eight so we lived in
an all-white neighborhood and I attended
an all-white public school while my
parents helped found a multiracial
Church in downtown Cape Town because I
was so young it was impossible for me to
understand the magnitude of what was
happening in South Africa at that time I
witnessed the racism and oppression of
people of color I knew and loved on a
daily basis but because of my own skin
colour there was no way I could fully
comprehend it but I had the privilege to
experience firsthand one of the most
influential social movements of the 20th
century and the thing that left a long
lasting impression on me was how the
people I met in South Africa could
envision a better future for themselves
and their country a future they really
believed was possible and then they
worked together
Lesly for decades until they achieved
that extraordinary historic change I was
there to see Nelson Mandela released
from prison and I watched an entire
country began a major transformation and
that transformed me as a person it
instilled in me a sense of wonder and
optimism and possibility that permeates
everything I create I make sculptures
like forever as a way of giving physical
tangible forms to language and time
those powerful but invisible forces that
shape the way we perceive and experience
our realities and in doing so I try to
give other people the opportunity to
reflect on their own perception of
reality and inspire them to wonder and
imagine what else might be possible I
often use science to do this because how
simply and effectively they're able to
grab our attention and communicate
information they often point out things
we would otherwise overlook like this
sign on the side of the highway in Texas
they can often signify things that we
can't see at all like the distance to
our destination signs often help to
orient us in the world by telling us
where we are now and what's happening in
the present moment but they can also
help us zoom out shift our perspective
and get a glimpse of the bigger picture
imagine for example you're walking down
the street in Philadelphia a city in the
US that contains so much history the
birthplace of our Constitution but
imagine you're walking down the street
in an area that's undergoing a huge
transformation due to gentrification and
as you walk down that street you notice
something flashing up above you so you
look up and you see this flashing neon
sign that says all the light you see is
from the past
and then all you see is past before
turning off completely for a brief
moment it asks you to stop and notice
the history embedded and everything that
you see and it reminds you that because
light takes time to travel across space
even from just across the street or
across the room everything you're seeing
in the present moment is technically an
image of the past science influenced the
way we all navigate the world which
means they have the ability to create a
collective experience or understanding
my time in South Africa taught me that
when people are able to find common
ground and work together towards a
mutual goal powerful things can happen
and so much more becomes possible and I
want to create more opportunities for
people to find that kind of common
ground I want people to feel the power
of collaboration sometimes quite
literally a few years ago a friend of
mine showed me how our bodies can safely
conduct small amounts of electricity and
if you hold hands with another person a
small electrical current can pass
through your held hands and become like
a switch that can trigger something else
to happen so last year I used that form
of human connection to activate an
inflatable sculpture I put two sensors
on a platform far enough apart so that
one person can't make it work on their
own but when two or more people work
together to complete that electrical
circuit the inflatable comes to life and
it begins to fill with air and the
longer people hold hands the larger it
becomes expanding into the words you are
magic
I always love to see how each group of
people finds a different way to bridge
that physical and metaphorical divide
but as soon as they release their hands
and break that connection the words
immediately begin to slouch and fall
over and eventually return to a lifeless
pile of fabric on the ground
[Applause]
[Music]
at this moment in time I think we could
all agree that the future feels pretty
bleak and uncertain but maybe the hope
for a brighter more sustainable more
equitable future depends first on our
ability to imagine it but after we
imagine it we actually have to believe
it's possible and then we have to find
common ground with people we would maybe
otherwise disagree with and work
together towards that mutual goal and if
we do that I believe we have the
capacity for magic so if you can humor
me for one more minute I'm going to ask
everyone in this theater to hold hands
when's the last time you held hands with
a stranger and if you feel comfortable
go ahead and make that metaphorical
gesture of reaching across the aisle and
after you've held hands with people on
either side of you if you feel
comfortable please close your eyes now
take a minute to imagine what you want
what you want the future to look like
and give yourself permission to be at
least a little bit idealistic what do
you want to see change or happen in your
own life as an individual what do you
want to see change or happen for
everyone for the planet can you picture
it and can you start to see how if we
all worked together it might actually be
possible now open your eyes and let's
make it real thank you
[Applause]
[Music]